das hier ist die beste Pizza die du zu
Hause Backen kannst du brauchst keinen
teuren Pizzaofen sondern nur einen
normalen Backofen okay okay ich habe
einen Fehler gemacht immer wenn es auf
meinem Kanal in der letzten Zeit um
Pizza ging dann um Pizza napoletana egal
ob beim Weltmeister in food Spots oder
bei meiner 30 Stunden Pizza doch es gibt
noch eine andere Pizza die ist genauso
verdient hat gesehen zu werden New York
Style Pizza dünn knusprig lecker und so
viel mehr als die American Pizza
Lieferservice ist hier in Deutschland an
von italienischen Emigranten nach New
York gebracht hat sich die Pizza
unabhängig weiterentwickelt heutzutage
gehört sie zum Stadtbild genauso wie
hotdog-stände Wolkenkratzer und volle
Straße aber eine Sache macht sie für das
heutige Video wirklich perfekt während
Pizza napoletana extreme Temperaturen
und kurze Backzeiten benötigt kann man
New York Style Pizza perfekt im
heimischen Backofen backen machen wir
uns an die Arbeit beginnen wir mit der
vermeintlich wichtigsten Zutaten ich
habe ja schon alles stehen was wir
brauchen und das ist gar nicht mal so
viel ein bisschen Salz Mehl Hefe
und Zucker sowie ein bisschen lauwarmes
Wasser sollte man eigentlich immer zu
Hause haben und das ist auch
beeindruckend denn es geht nicht nur
schnell sondern die Zutaten sind super
simpel deshalb ist es die perfekte Pizza
für zu Hause zu unserem lauwarmen Wasser
geben wir jetzt etwas Zucker nicht
strenge italienisch aber die Pizza die
wir machen ist ja auch eine New York
Style Pizza zumal der Zucker einen
weiteren Vorteil hat er bräunt nämlich
unseren Teig mit einer weiteren Zutaten
die wir später hinzugeben schneller das
heißt niedrige Temperaturen als im Profi
Pizzaofen wie schaffen wir die Bräune
mit solchen kleinen Tricks das Rezept
zum Teig ist übrigens von Adam einen
amerikanischer Youtuber der sehr sehr
nice Videos macht verlinke ich euch auch
unten ich habe auch ganz ganz viele
verschiedene Rezepte verglichen und das
ist das beste eine Sache fast vergessen
natürlich muss das blockchain im
Hintergrund gleich Leuchten gehen wir
jetzt die Hefe dazu ich kann es gerade
selbst kaum fassen wie einfach dieser
Teig ist ich meine ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht ich habe schon häufiger Pizza
gemacht und immer wenn ich das mache
mache ich eine Bieger also ein Vorteil
der über Nacht steht bei Raumtemperatur
dann vermische ich das mit dem Rest vom
Teig und hier schmeißen wir einfach
alles zusammen langsam warten ein
bisschen und haben einen richtig geilen
Teig das Ding ist so schnell und Zeit
effizient kann man keine napolitanische
Pizza machen weil die halt Zeit braucht
damit der Rand zu hoch wird und so
weiter und so fort aber wir wollen das
gar nicht erzielen wir wollen eine
knusprige dünne knackige Pizza haben als
nächstes gehen wir noch das Salz dazu
und dann können wir auch schon unser
Mehl in die Rührschüssel geben unsere
hefe Zucker Salz Flüssigkeit einfach
ganz entspannt dazu schütten und die
Hälfte auf die Arbeitsfläche verteilen
und das hilft ebenfalls im bräunen vom
Teig zwei drei Esslöffel Olivenöl dazu
die werden auch mit in den Teig
eingearbeitet und das ist laut Adam eine
Sache die man machen kann aber nicht
muss wir machen es weil seine Pizza
sieht einfach zu krass aus also
okay Leute wir haben ein bisschen rum
experimentiert und wir brauchen
definitiv ich weiß nicht was es ist
Proteinanteil im Mehl die Hefe keine
Ahnung wir brauchen auf jeden Fall
weniger Wasser als es in dem Rezept von
Adam ist wir sind jetzt bei 400 ml
gelandet er hat 530 also schon
ordentlicher Unterschied aber ich denke
mal dass wir jetzt einen Teig haben mit
dem wir weiter arbeiten können ich nehme
jetzt ein bisschen Mehl auf das Brett
und hole meinen Teig heraus knete ihn
jetzt noch ein bisschen von Hand weiter
sollte eigentlich nicht notwendig sein
aber erwartet diese special Konsistenz
diesen Teig teile ich jetzt auf so dass
ich ihn in vier Schüsseln portionieren
kann ohne ihn vorher noch mal unzulassen
einfach so wie er ist klappen wir uns
machen das Ganze mit Augenmaß einfach
dann halbiert ist halbieren wir noch mal
jetzt nehmen wir den Teig wollen in den
kleinen Kügelchen der altbekannten
Technik so die kleinen Finger unten
zusammenführen und am Ende noch mal so
mit dem Handballen drüber dass sich das
unten weitestgehend schließt wir haben
vier gleich große Pizza Ballen mit den
werde ich jetzt quasi als Pinsel Ersatz
hier einmal einfetten jede Schüssel
kommt ein bisschen Olivenöl rein mit dem
Teigbällchen so dass wir quasi einmal
alles gepinseln können right 1 machen
wir das jetzt mit allem und dann wartet
man 2 Stunden bei Raumtemperatur oder
bis zu 2 Tage im Kühlschrank und wir
können uns jetzt schon mal um die Pizza
Soße alles was wir dafür brauchen ist
ein bisschen Olivenöl ein bisschen
Zucker keine Sorge wir nehmen nicht
alles davon Oregano und ich habe mich
für Cherry Tomaten aus der Dose
entschieden mit dem ganz bestimmten
Grund ich will nicht so viel Zucker
günstig hinzufügen wird trotzdem so
dieses amerikanische was so eine leichte
Süße Note hat und die sind einfach mal
viel süßer als normale Tomaten Vorsicht
heute wieder perfekt und weißes T-Shirt
angezogen
zerdrücke ich die mit meiner Hand
dadurch bleiben die kleinen Kerne intakt
wenn wir das nämlich jetzt pürieren
würden wenn wir die einfach quasi mit
pürieren die Soße wird ein bisschen
bitter werden und wir wollen ja eben die
süße in den Vordergrund heben und wenn
ich die ausgequetscht habe bleiben die
Schalen so praktisch in der Hand zurück
und die nehme ich einmal raus weil die
auf der Pizza zu haben das muss nicht
sein so viel Haut von den Tomaten habe
ich noch rausgeholt also es ist schon
extra step den muss man nicht unbedingt
machen aber die haben 25 % mehr
natürlichen Zucker bisschen süßer
abschmecken wenn wir das Ganze trotzdem
auch mit einer kleinen Prise Zucker dann
eben Oregano dazu habe ich sonst nicht
in meiner Tomatensoße aber heute wollen
wir andere Pizza als napolitanische
ordentliche Prise Salz und Olivenöl
probiere das ganze jetzt mal wow aber
die süße weckt direkt dieses Bild von so
einer American Pizza ist mir noch ein
bisschen zu flüssig ich gebe noch ein
bisschen Tomatenmark dazu das deckt das
ganze ein bisschen ein und wir haben
noch mehr diesen intensiven
Tomatengeschmack dieses kleine Ding hier
macht unsere Pizza so viel besser das
ist ein
steil den kriegt man bei Amazon bei
einem gut sortierten Küchenladen der ist
richtig schwer also der wiegt bestimmt
45 Kilo ist massiv und speichert die
Hitze gibt sie dann an unsere Pizza ab
unbedingt beim vorheizen mit reinhauen
ein Pizza Stein ist die zweitbeste
Option und die dritte beste Option ist
dass man das ganze einfach auf dem
Backblech macht mit so einem
vorgeheizten Stahl kriegt man aber im
Idealfall von unten eine schöne tigerung
hin und das zeichnet eben eine richtig
gute Pizza aus deshalb jetzt ab in den
Ofen und in den zweiten Schlitz von oben
Backofen Einstellungen sind im Prinzip
so heiß wie es irgendwie geht ich habe
jetzt 260 Grad bei Umluft mit
Grillfunktion wir können aber auch ober
Unterhitze Hauptsache irgendwie heiß
wenn man den Grill aber in irgendeiner
Form noch mitnimmt hat man das Backstein
unter dem Grill der wird richtig schön
heiß und es wird auch von oben geräumt
deshalb habe ich diese Einstellung
genommen auf Temperatur kommen lassen
und dann noch mal 10 Minuten heizen
lassen so dass wirklich der Stahl
komplett durch erhitzt wird das ist
wichtig weil er die Hitze speichert und
dann an die Pizza abgeht wenn wir
drauflegen also ein bisschen warten der
Backofen ist in der Grillfunktion auf
300 Grad vorgeheizt ich habe jetzt auf
umluftgrill gestellt und hier ist alles
was wir für unsere Pizzen endgültig
brauchen verschiedene Sorten Käse seht
ihr hier ein bisschen Parmesan einfach
für die Soße noch und das hier ist
eigentlich der gleiche Käse Mozzarella
gerieben so wie man ihn kennt aus dem
Supermarkt und das hier sind so cheese
Sticks die ich an der Käse Theke geholt
habe einfach klein geschnitten beide
haben eine Sache gemeinsam es ist
Schnitt fest am Mozzarella ist härter
schmilzt besser und hinterlässt keine
kleinen Pfützchen auf unserer Pizza so
wie es wäre wenn wir das jetzt mit
frischer Mozzarella machen würden wir
wollen richtig viel Käse drauf verteilen
und deshalb brauchen wir einen trockenen
Käse haben wir uns als Backen unser Teig
ist richtig schön aufgegangen ich nehme
hier mal ein ich gebe schon mal ein
bisschen Mehl auf meine Arbeitsfläche
zack der kommt sehr sehr schön raus und
bei beiden Seiten wird er jetzt
ordentlich gemailt anders als bei der
napolitanischen Pizza Formen wir jetzt
keinen klassischen Rand sondern wir
lassen die Pizza durch die Hand gehen
und sich ordentlich ausbreiten ihr merkt
das geht wie von selbst sehr sehr
leichtgängig der Teig schaut mal wie
schön dünn der ist es bilden sich schon
fast so kleine Löcher und jetzt hier ist
noch kein Meister vom Himmel gefallen
ich habe auch noch nicht häufig mit
dieser Art Teig gearbeitet ziehen wir
den einfach irgendwie in Form das schöne
ist ja wir machen homemade Pizza sie
muss nicht perfekt rund sein sondern
einfach so wie wir es hinbekommen jetzt
nehme ich hier mein Pizzablech wenn ihr
keins habt wovon ich ausgehe könnt ihr
auch einfach von dem Pizza Karton den
Deckel benutzen und reinzuschieben ein
Holztreppen flammkuchenbrett irgendwie
irgendwas ihr könnt erst mal im
trockenen Zustand ohne heißen Ofen
testen wie das für euch funktioniert so
Pizza drauf und ich belege immer ganz
gern oben auf meinem Blech drauf weil es
einfach chillig ist oder muss ich nicht
belegt drauf ziehen die Pizza geht nicht
kaputt zuerst unsere Tomatensoße und wir
können anfangen sie zu verteilen auf die
tomatenbasis gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen
Parmesan der macht das Ganze noch
würziger parmes natürlich deutlich
kräftiger im Geschmack als der
Mozzarella den wir später benutzen gehen
wir an mit unserem schnittfesten
Mozzarella Käse den verteile ich einfach
hier drauf ich bin gespannt wie der
perform im Vergleich zum geriebenen
Mozzarella Ende des Tages sollte alles
zu einer schönen käsedecke verschmelzen
und ganz wichtiger Test steht noch an
und zwar bewegt es sich und es bewegt
sich perfekt das heißt ab in den Ofen
eine kräftige Bewegung zu machen und
jetzt 5 bis 6 Minuten warten aber
verlasst euch nicht auf die Zeit sondern
guckt mit euren Augen waren die Farbe
erreicht ist guckt euch das an unsere
Pizza ist durchgebacken und wie sie
durchgebackmäßige Ecke hoch in der Luft
Freunde
wow alter Schwede guckt euch das einfach
mal an unsere nächste Pizza gehen wir
einfach nur Unmengen Mozzarella Käse bei
so soll sie sein richtig schön bedeckt
mit einem Deckel aus Mozzarella der
einfach gut schmeckt ab in den Ofen mit
Nummer zwei
man muss wirklich beim Pizza backen
mutig sein egal ob es Pizza auf das
Blech runter vom Blech einfach schnelle
Bewegung mutige Bewegung wenn ihr jetzt
so langsam anfängt vertraut mir das geht
nicht gut ich habe schon die ein oder
andere Pizza verkackt da war dann immer
die Kamera aus zum Glück Alter schwedet
ihr dieses Meer aus Käse das langsam von
weiß zu braun wird
ich kann es nicht mehr abwarten Mamma
Mia das sieht verdammt gut aus schaut
mal wie die vor sich hin blubbert wir
haben leichte Farbe am Rand der erste
ist ein bisschen zu wenig belegt gewesen
zu wenig Käse aber ich sehe jetzt schon
dass der einfache geriebene Mozzarella
unser go to ist ich weiß noch eine
Mischung aus beiden dritte Variante wir
machen einfach mehr von allem die Pizza
ist auch größer geworden vielleicht ist
das auch der Trick denn es ist ja eine
amerikanische Pizza
mehr Geschmack mehr Fett soll schon
passieren wenn man zu viel Käse drauf
geht ja was passieren ist die Frage mit
deinem Körper und deiner Gesundheit kann
wahrscheinlich ja da kann was passieren
ja und die letzten im Bunde ist fertig
gucken wir uns einmal an String Cheats
ihr seht ne ein bisschen traurig
bisschen zu wenig drauf gewesen sowohl
von Tomatensoße als auch von Käse die
andere mit nur den Mozzarella Käse sieht
schon fast perfekt aus muss ich sagen
und hier zum Abschluss die Version mit
richtig viel Käse richtig viel Soße ist
die schönste eine von den beiden ist es
probieren wir jetzt unsere Kreation
schön dünn wirklich verdammt dünn guckt
euch mal an da ist teilweise gar kein
Platz mehr zum Boden knusprig ist sie
wir können sie Falten
es ist wirklich einfach genau diese
Variante Pizza die ich noch nie selbst
gemacht habe und es hat so gut
funktioniert das ist einfach eine
bessere lieferpizza das ist einfach so
schön ausbalanciert wir haben die Süße
von den Tomaten frische gleichzeitig
leichte oreganote aber vor allem einfach
diesen schönen Teig der auch noch
richtig knusprig ist nein das war nicht
nachträglich hinzugefühlt ich das
einfach selbst zu Hause im Backofen
gebacken hat kann ich mir kaum
vorstellen ich habe ja sonst diesen
fernsehpizza offen und den habe ich mir
auch eigentlich mit einem Grund gekauft
weil ich dachte eigentlich dass man
nicht so gute Pizza und normalen
Backofen machen kann ich glaube durch
Feintuning mit vorheizen Ofen
Einstellung kann man noch so viel machen
das hier war eine Margarita tägt mich
mal wenn ihr irgendwelche Kunden
Kreation macht lasst Euch schmecken und
ciao